was ist ihr thema für die
bürgerschaftswahl wonach entscheiden sie
wie in die wählen
wonach ich entscheide
sozialpolitik rentenbetrag ja was ist
für mich ein thema wohnung war also um
ehrlich zu sein habe ich in letzter zeit
meinen letzten jahr nicht viel
mitbekommen von veränderungen oder so
etwas für mich ist alles gleich
geblieben im groben jetzt dass man den
auf vertrauen kann dass wenn man gewisse
basis da ist dass man den leuten auch
das waren auch dazu kommt dass man
probleme auch anspricht muss ganz
ehrlich sagen im moment ist hier gern
schlecht zu sagen es ist ob sie die
grünen nehmen die gelben nehmen oder die
roben nehmen die haben alle ihre
ansichten und die tun im grunde genommen
die machen nur das was sie wollen und
nicht was die bevölkerung gerne möchte
man haben sie sich schon entschieden was
sie wären am sonntag ja und was bestimmt
ihre wahlentscheidung was ist für sie
ein wichtiges thema in hamburg wichtiges
thema in hamburg ist für mich ein mal
dass bildung hier besser praktiziert
wird als bisher praktiziert wird und
natürlich auch die ganze misere in den
stausee in der hand wo ich umweltschutz
es gibt integration immer noch es gibt
natürlich das verkehrswesen was da
ausgebaut werden muss dass das netz so
zu sagen da gibt es ganz viele die
wirtschaft ist für mich wichtig an
falscher stelle umwelt aber wichtiger
scheint mir im moment die wirtschaft für
mich ist schon jahrelang
ganz wichtig dass dass es um die kinder
auch vor allen dingen geht gerade jetzt
als mutter
wie gesagt das ist christlich ist mir
auch sehr wichtig dass in der partei
vorkommt daneben das ja alle
menschenrechte gibt also die die man für
alle gleich machen könnte ich weiß es
thema elite ist bei uns in unserem lande
nicht gerne gehört aber ich finde wir
sollten uns nicht schämen auch ihr leben
wieder zu fördern
das heißt kinder die mehr potenzial
haben auch tatsächlich denen wir jetzt
futter zu bieten und ich glaube das
spiel das im moment nicht darstellen
kann weil sie einfach mit den anderen so
beschäftigt sind und auch die lehrer
allein gelassen werden für mich ist
eigentlich schon seit zwei
legislaturperioden das thema
elbvertiefung wichtiges ansonsten ist
mir auch wichtig wir sind zu schauen
welche parteien sich um die
infrastruktur hamburgs kümmern
und was mit haushaltsüberschüssen
passiert das spannend das ist natürlich
sinnvoll dann schulden abzubauen
partiell hamburg hat 104 stadtteile und
wir müssen einfach sehen dass nicht nur
das rathaus und die parteien die wichtig
sind sondern dass die stadtteile
eigentlich hamburg ausmachen
das heißt die 104 stadtteile müssen je
nach ihrem charakter so organisiert
werden dass sie an einem nachhaltigen
gemeinsamen leben insgesamt in der
metropolregion teilnehmen ich bin
selbstständiger im grunde genommen war
es bei mir so ich muss meine partei wäre
die meine interessen vertritt und für
selbstständige wie ich bin ein kleines
geschäft
da sind sind nicht mehr alle türen offen
da wird für meine bedingung zu wenig
gemacht
gewisse leute die im kleineren bereich
sind im großen
der große groß ist ja die andere partei
das ist der große kreis hier fast in
ganz deutschland jetzt haben wir partei
das ist das will keiner aber das ist
auch eine eine wahlergebnis weil die
anderen für seinen fehler gemacht also
nur daher resultiert das halt hier so
groß geworden ist
ich hoffe ja dass das diesmal wieder aus
dann glaube ich nicht so
und das haben die wahlkämpfe auch in
haben wo ich gut hingekriegt finde ich
dass es deutlich ist dass es sich um
eine landtagswahl also eine
bürgerschaftswahl handelt das ist auch
ganz wichtig gewesen angesichts dieser
ereignisse in thüringen